sie stiegen flüge flüge mit der
akupunktur
hängen
[Musik]
sieger
wurde
[Musik]
adrian und theres panetta prüfe
karibische insel der lokführer und die
bosch tag stellt die ein kluger vom
leben nach fahrplan
der weg zum eigenen die haie ist für die
zwei jungs wanderer aber kein einfaches
sie
[Musik]
ich will diese findet die erste theres
und dem claudio hat gott ganz zur
vernunft der isla margarita wo sie
zweimal mit einer rufe dir wohnen
[Musik]
als paradies für die beiden auswanderer
ist petrows land steckt in einer tiefen
wirtschaftskrise
größten schlager vorderleute und
kriminalität steigt
und haben wir den cup zwischen den autos
und seine trauer und dann hätten wir
noch eine zentriert mit klaren
sieger
[Musik]
der traum vom us wanderer siebziger
jahre begleitet und schweizer auf ihrem
weg ins neues label wie der allerersten
staffel ist das bündner bei abrufen
insel in der karibik
und hübsch einziges glück gefunden
[Musik]
zum gruße finden sich oft ist er
hingehört zu venezuela
eine so gross wie der kanton thurgau
von claudio candrian und touristen die
am hannover es ist das quartier wo die
besser situiert bewohnen
sie hätten vor qualmt es hieß berühmt
[Applaus]
das heißt ich muss
noch
viel
zu viel auf der welt ausgesetzt doch
linie kartons unterwelt der abschnitt
von viel laufen mussten er schwer
wirklich zählen
ausgewandert sind 280 ganz allein
knapp 30 jahre lang war claudio candrian
bei der rhätischen bahn angestellt der
führerstand der lok war sein arbeitsort
ein einsamer job
[Musik]
wenig dass sie da nicht unbedingt dicht
sparen
über dem wasser
noch für wenige tage wohnt er im
bündnerischen maienfeld
doch uns nächstes er ihn wirklich und
die shoah du hast du schon
innerhalb beschleunigen
und somit unter person daily noch
schnell gepostet dominique ob teheran
den toaster monate war wirklich klasse
rohstoff nicht dafür viel kopfarbeit er
ist da schon in der luft ohne
übergepäck mit nur zwei koffern geht's
ab auf die insel
ok
[Musik]
claudio und theres verabschieden sich
von ihren liebsten
[Musik]
die beiden lassen erwachsene kinder aus
erster ehe zurück doch nun wartet die
zukunft
und die heißt wie mehr arbeiten und das
leben in der eigenen villa genießen das
werden wir
[Musik]
sind da
und da immer diese aussicht
[Musik]
ist
das
anwaltsbüro
gar nichts klappt es erwartet sie ein
unterschriftsreifer vertrag und auch der
abgemachte preis gilt plötzlich nicht
mehr
rechnen und verhandeln mit der
italienischen besitzerin des grundstücks
und deren anwälte
es kommt zu einer einigung aber zu einem
dreimal höheren preis 60000 franken
[Musik]
auf der baustelle geht es nun ordentlich
voran doch bis die arbeiter überhaupt
loslegen konnten mussten claudio und
theres nochmals umgerechnet 1500 franken
locker machen
können hätte schmerzt wenn man ein
architekt hätte das messer absegnen und
der hätte für das die hohle hand gemacht
drittens vor zwölf millionen
hat heldt mit der photo gemeint sondern
im fernsehen ist erhält man den kauf die
drei architekten der jeder 1,5 millionen
und könnte mit einer bauhausbauten in
diesem haus wohnen die auswanderer
vorübergehend zur miete hier erlebte
tieres jüngst einen überfall
und haben quelle aba kofferträger und in
dem moment ist es losgegangen
schlag am kopf
eigentlich wollte es claudio ruhiger
angehen lassen auf der insel doch schon
bald beginnt der gelernte
maschinenschlosser als automechaniker zu
arbeiten
[Musik]
die bauarbeiten am haus ziehen sich
unerwartet in die länge der rohbau ist
immer noch nicht ganz fertig
claudius mit seiner geduld langsam am
ende
das ist oft
viel geduld braucht
irgendwann
das visum kann
und darf mit
und dann
und dass er klappert und 68 und das ist
schlecht
also was dem auge
stocker das
geschafft
was ist das für eine mannschaft
immer jeden tag in der autowerkstatt
die große angst
nach
218 8
nebenher stumpen ist prima hat dass dem
nicht so viel
aber drei vier stunden
ist mir jetzt das ist für die wirtschaft
statt dazu vom büro schafhalter putzfrau
aber sie schrie sektor ja sie spielt
großen und kleinen buch zu werden immer
so viel wahrscheinlich dass bruch im
raum ist jetzt sagen wir ein duales
mehreren zonen während wäre haben jetzt
militär und dort geld aber erforscht
dass wir hier sind
es ist komisch was wir sind doch und
könig erarbeitet und da lorenz die hartz
iv
wenn ich kam helfer schoss
musste das media susanne lehr dreifach
also ich bin froh wenn ich so cannabis
und helfer und der kreis
web.de
ihr freund lütow je länger je mehr
brauche venezuela steckt in einer
schlimmen wirtschaftskrise sozialistisch
regierte land hat die höchste inflation
für die ganze welt die heimische geld
der bolivar strom jeder tag weniger wert
glücklich sind die ausländisches geld
hat er es unter claudio sie werden von
tag zu tag riegel
am claudia schiess geschäft lauf trotz
der krise gut er sie zuverlässig und
liefere solide bier zeit um mir verzählt
schweizer haut also für die in ihrer
über 15 mal mehr als ein
durchschnittlicher venezolanischen
arbeit geschafft auf eigene rechnung in
ihrer werkstatt man sich mit zwei andere
das siegtor dass dieses büro da ist die
cloud und daniel und natürlich zwei als
regierungschef
wäre ich nicht ortes schöna schützen
zwischen schweiz und
der schotte job gefunden ja ja ja und
und sie dass sie sind rasch ist er
schnell vorstellen er ist
die haben ja
man spricht halt langsam moment wird und
dann aber ich muss man fördern das gar
nicht so warum also ich bin ich doch
dienstes zu schaffen du machst die durch
den film
fertig sein
die geologie das
also war es gar nicht dass du nur du
erstellst du so wie
wenn einer gewöhnt ist
immer das so ja immer mit system
scharfer der chronik der
aufstieg leise und den ab juni muss ich
jetzt mit den langen und dann gar nicht
den strand forscher versuchen drogen im
spiel
obwohl abstiegskampf
womit milito her sind und jetzt
eigentlich
nie mit
ihm daraus
70er es geht um aschersleben schönebeck
also nein also wegen geld ich nicht die
frau die zu sein ich denke das ist
den knapp 50 euro
ob die hat die hat und ich mache im auto
das läuft jetzt aber gut und hat modern
überließ das geld
will barzahler ist gewöhnlich also ist
es wirklich so kriminell
hatte für das handy ist das leben über
den sie je nachdem wie hat ihnen
die sterne die haie oder
waffenbesitz ist strengstens verboten
offiziell
wenn er nun los wie der in denen für
event ist okay aber blöd ist wenn der
strom aus dann gehts problem ja der witz
amerika wurden
ich glaube ich ständig bedroht fühle
wenn ich langsam nachdem da ab wo geld
im sack kaufen soll darf nicht versuchen
unabhängig übrig oder arm
wirtschaftskrise zwingt zu ela betrifft
alle kleider sind leer milch zu cabrio
kosmetik oder putzmittel für ganz
alltägliche sache stellt manager stunde
lang
[Musik]
robuste das ist venezuela gröbere
überblick der i.syde das macht sie für
ein so richtig glücklich wenn sie
irgendwo ein park wc papier film
und jetzt gottes rat zuvor trotz mancher
news aus zürich
überall menschenschlange
moment
dafür ein abriss körner heiligkreuz
tarantini also setzt der film ist europa
voll
salate die
bundesliga so schlimm und mehr geht es
darum im frühling seine tochter hätte
zyklik können aber scharfer sie hätte
mir sogar staaten uhr geöffnet das 60
aber das sind es dir stehen zu ihrer
grundausstattung
das muss man
grundnahrungsmittel
eigentlich schlimmer da sind
ddp.djn
grundnahrungsmittel
überraschte was sie wohl stimmt - und
das meist
nicht denn es versteht und das öl
aufnehmen
rechten auges einen tisch
es gibt zwei theorien die verbreitete
meinung planwirtschaft vor der
sozialistische regierung die schuld dass
es die sache gibt regierung selber
behauptete gegen die kapitalistische
position der grundnahrungsmittel horten
umzug karte zum bevölkerung um 4
halo hat es katzenfutter förderloch nein
nichts
oder mutter grad durch die straßen
tragen bis zum
der ist erzählt dass die rotter wenn es
denn überhaupt über und die letzte mühle
zum portier wurde ein großer sack
hundefutter ist jetzt acht musik bolivar
also gleich viel wie der mindestlohn von
venezolaner
weißt du was
apa
mit 5
beim stopp an der tankstelle zwei sachen
teresa vier majors office herz und zwei
zähler ich benzin
unvorstellbar billig
wie geht's dir gut gut
und gut dank vorbei
dank war klagt bietet er ist dass es
timo stieg
und auch das wasser wird immer teurer
die 20 liter flaschen
das klingt ja das kostet jetzt 250 bulli
war
das ist viel und das benzin ist so
billig aber wir können das hat auch
nicht
[Gelächter]
großzügiges trinkgeld fast zehnfache von
dem was benzin kostet theoretisch
vermutlich die beliebt ist die runden
überhaupt an einer tankstelle
das land ist wirklich unglaublich fürs
gleiche geld kann dann entweder und sagt
hundefutter posten oder 80 liter benzin
venezuela als reich beschenkt
lamprecht die natur und vor allem die
größte erde reserve vor der ganzen welt
die sozialistische regierung hat land
davon profitiert jetzt und öle so billig
ist richtig anziehen wirtschaft seien
essbar woche nach dem 2 1 der
benzinpreis übrigens um 60 fachen tour
zum der staatsbankrott beenden
[Musik]
dem land wird immer schwieriger
warum weint er ist unter claudio
trotzdem unbedingt da bliebe so ganz
verstehen
so
ist wenn es
nass ist eine kommission von und
mit einer hand
was ist wenn es mit 15 10 karten sind
für den halt machen
man kann
das ganze stück
[Musik]
das kind
sucht die starken
[Musik]
im garten oder theres und claudio ist
zufrieden
[Musik]
aber außerdem uhr hört idylle schnell
luftraums hohes gut gesichert neu mit
elektrisch noch höher also wir tag und
den himmel sagt winter komischerweise
nicht reagiert im letzten moment
also gestohlen und in ihm das leben in
dem moment gestand und bin hinter dem
oberhofer und haben zugang schuster
welle aber gabi stock zimmer in dem der
toten sortenreine formiert und helmi den
praktischen der nato die trauer und dann
hätte mir nur eine zentriert mit der
knarre sowas war
aber das ergebnis der schnarcher dann in
den märz ist man weg macht
und damit liegt und dann heiraten und
sie sorgt festwirt und dann muss man
ruhig sie schon die natürlich schnell
aus und
doch wie sieht denn der overclock von
exit also sind nur zwei xiii aber ohne
der fans mit einem trick sie wurde es in
empfang genommen also ich stelle mir das
total dramatisch für mich
immer gerechnet neben claudia immer
gesagt haben die armut ist nicht so hoch
dass china und indien zweiter tag kunden
bedienen
ronny weller glaube du glaubst du denn
wer das mit dem zug nach
vorn ich glaub ich bin nur noch um
stunden wir locken sie das alles nimmt
es gott wahrscheinlich nicht anders wenn
es da länger aushalten als
rezept gebäude müsse sich selbst helfen
claudio wird es elektrisches garagentor
und
für das muss auch kabel verlegt
meistens springen
auf diese berufsgruppe strom oder dem
tode
seines coaches erstaunen
historismus in das rohr gefördert
naja
das kann sie sogar druck
ich weiß
nicht wieso
bruno
h
es ist wirklich gut
nein das ist nico das konto schnell ins
depot sieht und zu ihrer magath dem nach
dem 3 1 0 1
saisontor vier liter auto schnell ist
ja
da hat sich zwei kunde
sieht 16 jahres in theres unter claudio
s bahn
krise
aber ist ein anbieterwechsel oder bezirk
mit den anzieht sie
sagt es muss
[Musik]
ja ja
ja
das habe ich bis jetzt nicht mehr dass
sie sich also
dort
an der nase und hätte
dazu kräftig oder rote sauce und
daten ändert sich und man endlich und
offiziere
direkte und wenn mir etwas nicht passt
dann kann es auch sega bei diesen
aufträgen
unternehmen von moskau nach st
und da ist reine eine förderung
das wäre die
frau der welt themen stellt das wort wir
das geht nicht im garten kultiviert
putze hier könnten also für das prisma
hallo
schönheit
natürlich schon sehr viel wert drauf
aber mit putzen und so
und unter claudio hat dass ich irgendwie
verändert ja ja
ja nur selten zum gebot
der bündner in der karibik
claudia begleitet zum auto teilige
posten von anderen übernahmen für ihn
[Applaus]
oder
geistig wie die meisten anderen vertritt
zum schutz gegen überfälle
wieder prekäre wirtschaftliche situation
ist autoteile porsche immer glücksache
diesmal aber findet claudio alles im
ersten anlauf und
[Musik]
mit
karte
bargeld
zeisberg der gp die skulptur auf oder
wer stadt verewigen
[Musik]
claudio schon wieder an wenn jetzt im
ruf höhere am samstag scharfe erzählt er
ist
richtig
dass nicht das ist
ich bin vielleicht besonders gut wo
etwas neues machen
so gut aussieht für
und ich habe 100 verstehen dass ich auch
noch nicht eigentlich
letzten als ich habe recht eigentlich
möchten viel gesagt
eigentlich aber die schweiz ja
solange ich liebe glaubt
betragen als pensionär ist nicht
notwendig und zulässig da also ganz
schlimm werde weiß dass ich mir sorgen
tritt jetzt kümmern oder also gab es
viele werte punkt erreicht mit der
wirtschaft gleich wieder heftig knoten
aber ihr mit
im gegenteil
da
relativ gut
und hat das mit
[Gelächter]
befriedigend und 80 arzt sind an
claudias herz gewachsen aber es ist
resultat so viel hilfe darf durch
der hund ist de facto volumen
bleibt die meiste zeit forum hus führen
straße und hetero recht gut damit
flecker fordert ihr erfüllt die 58 jahre
geht er ist sie hat sich venezuelas erst
widerruf dieser suche zurück in der
schweiz hat sie lang als voll pakt
bleibe k als alleinerziehende mutter war
100 prozent wieder geschafft hat
mit ihrer erwachsenen sind skype at rees
und claudio regelmäßig sie trotzdem noch
die häufiger will die beiden jetzt es
gemeinsam senkel hinten die familie
geschichte ist wirklich speziell
von claudia
clark sie dass das erst im herbst
enkeltochter domenica ist jetzt das halb
so laut großeltern heinz baby shop sucht
[Musik]
politische wenn die magische partys vor
mir
ist es jetzt anders als vorher war sie
2001 um sein kind die hand das
vorstellen
anders
die schweiz würden ich glaube da würde
mich
nicht entscheiden
will immer eine familie und handys
labour und die sagen einfach wir hatten
im federführenden schweizers mir den
hals schotten intensiv genießen
es ist schon komisch
bewusst bin nicht viel gedanken pflegen
ja weil sie schlichtweg nicht einfach
ist das leben ja doch sich auch spiel
gleich nach dem rennen wie so vieles
fällt ein ziel gefunden was sie brauchen
mehreren strand gemüse ist für sie
stühle sowie spanne zu wichtig das gibt
es am buch ein andermal oder mit geistes
der schweiz sowie mit mir
davon aktive auch immer noch
glücklich wo ich bin schon etwas so
schnell aber jetzt moment einer kurzen
aber das ist ja schon mal der tag ist
das ist das erfolgsrezept
beim begrüßt hätten was läuft
und glücklich ist dass der receiver
jahren oder aus
internet abhängig
da einfach das mitgeteilt dass das für
zehn minuten also fern verlag.de und
schlösser das gibt's nicht
zwei männerteams uhr auf der isla
margarita schickt man die beide als sms
sz normal acht mitglieder zu erhöhen im
haushalt noch league platz und im herz
von einer weide sowieso
[Musik]
er hat familie schmid ihres lebens kopf
stellt und sagt auf australien
[Musik]
juni sie jetzt ganz so happy grad wieder
an neujahr von asus ein anderer job für
die partie und es frisch geborenes baby
ich komme zwar bezieht vom zirkus stress
und vom ganz normalen familie wahnsinn
[Musik]
spezial nächsten kritik
schüler die auf der suche ist dahin
siegerin wurde
[Musik]